I think you know what I'm going to say
next I'd like to introduce the Lord
Mayor of Birmingham who is going to
declare the result of the parliamentary
constituency of Yardley Lord Mayor
results for Yardley constituency
Birmingham for seven - May 2015
I hereby declare that the total number
of votes given for each candidate is as
follows Bishop ground the green party
698 Clayton Paul Stephen UK Independence
Party six thousand six hundred thirty
seven Flynn Amman Kevin trade unionist
and socialist coalition 135 hemming John
Alexander Marvin Liberal Democrats ten
thousand five hundred thirty four
Johnson Peter Frank Social Democrat
Democratic Party 71 chest Phillips
Labour Party 17,000
Forte ahran the Conservative Party
candidate 5760 Stephens devil Marvin
Anthony respect peace justice equality
187 the number of rejected ballot paper
was 162 total 41,000 wondering 140 1313
this represents a majority of six
thousand five hundred ninety five for
Jess Phillips
who is duly elected to serve as member
for Birmingham yarn a constituency
turnout 57.2 six percent I would know in
white just Philips to come forward and
say a few words so thank you to the
returning officer and the brilliant
staff here in Birmingham who have run
the election so well I am so thankful to
the people of Yardley for putting their
trust in me I will never take it for
granted and I will work every single day
to keep it I do not stand here alone I
must say a huge thank you to the
hundreds of people who stood
shoulder-to-shoulder with me throughout
this campaign thank you to every person
who knocks a door in the rain thank you
to every person who spent hours talking
to people on the phone and took on the
letterboxes and dogs of Yardley you are
awesome with some special mentions to
Keith to Caroline to the Birmingham
Labor students to Sarah ward and of
course to matthew lloyd for keeping me
sane and sticky
with me I was taught to fight for
justice by my mother and father my mum
was the daughter of a dinner lady from
Yardley who was given a grant by the
Yardley greatest charity to keep poor
kids in education in the 60s she is no
longer with me but she taught me to
always speak up for those who have less
than you have to always fight to give
voice to the voiceless and to strive for
every child as you would slap strive for
your own children and so I will every
step of this campaign was worth fighting
for every bedroom tax victim for every
nurse left demoralized that every police
officer retired off and women's refuge
put at risk that was what kept us
knocking in the rain we knew that it was
a fight worth having even when it hurt I
am very proud to have been elected the
Labour Member of Parliament for Yardley
because I know that the Labour Party is
about everybody and not just the richest
few and I know we're all better off when
we are all better off thank you